everybody remembers your speech from
last year especially being a woman I
remember that speech and stuff that have
changed happy really I'm gonna ask you
what is the difference that you have
seen for women century speech it's very
exciting senator Hanna Beth Jackson and
Governor Brown pass the fair strongest
Fair Pay law in the country here in
California and that's really significant
because California's the tenth largest
economy in the world and that we just
launched the change.org /vr a petition
so women have equal rights in America is
it true that you said after last year's
Oscar speech that there were roles you
missed out on because of that speech
well I think yeah that I actually that I
lost her that I walked away from that
you walked away from or twerking sir do
you think well I know that there was an
issue with some a couple of things for
sure because they said something that
made it very obvious but it's okay you
know I do believe in karma
and and really before I said I knew
there was going to be some drama because
it would cost people money but there's
33 million women and kids that are
living in poverty in America with a
full-time working mom so we need to
address this and we need to address this
right away